(high pitched sound from engines)
I saw that you applied to the flight academy again.
I'm your new wingman, Sir.
The coil.
The local scum use it for cover to launch attacks.
This is their turf, So move when I move.
Keep your eyes open.
No sudden moves.
Who the hell are you?
We're OMC.
And OMC belongs to Satcom.
Is that your boss?
Are we supposed to be scared of him or something?
Yeah.
The OMC aren't the only ones listening into coms.
All ships. We are under attack by vandal forces. Repeat.
Vandal forces. Repeat. We're under attack.
There have been battles.
There have been losses.
Each and
everyone of you has proven yourself time and time again.
We will not lose this system!
We will not fall back.
We will win!
Because we have to.